welcome back to CBS this morning we have
an update on a case we've covered for
months now police in Idaho have arrested
a man who has long been under suspicion
that is chad de bel he married lori valo
after the death of his wife and her
husband hold that in your mind for a
second day bail and valo are accused in
the disappearance of their children
JJ valo and Ty Lee Ryan Jonathan
Vigliotti is covering this case and has
been for some time Jonathan good morning
this is a movement in the direction that
a lot of people feared what more do we
know about these new charges yeah and
good morning to you Tony we're still
waiting for police and prosecutors to
release more details about those charges
and the human remains found in chad de
belles backyard we sure learn more in a
press conference later this morning
meanwhile de Bella is being held without
bond police arrived at Chad Abel's house
Tuesday morning with shovels and backup
20 members of the FBI investigators
discovered what appeared to be a
unidentified human remains and an
autopsy will be conducted authorities
were carrying out a search warrant
connected to the disappearance of the
then seven-year-old JJ and 17 year old
Ty Lee according to rich Robertson a
private investigator hired by JJ's
grandparents all the digging appeared to
be in one location which suggests that
they had some information that led them
to a specific part of the property roads
around the property were shut down and a
bail handcuffed shortly after the
remains were discovered
Chad de Bell was taken into custody and
booked into the Fremont County Jail the
development comes more than three months
after the children's mother and des
belles new wife Lori Val O'Day Bell was
arrested for defying a court order to
prove her children were alive
the couple has refused to tell police
where they are this is the last known
image of JJ taken last September Ty Lee
was last seen earlier that month in
Yellowstone National Park
their mother was extradited to Idaho in
March from Hawaii where the couple had
relocated right after they married at
the time
police wanted to speak to them about the
children and Chad's former wife who had
died suddenly just two weeks before Chad
and Laura's wedding her death is also
under investigation results of an
autopsy are pending des belles home was
first searched in January but at the
time that yard was covered with snow
JD's grandparents released a statement
saying it is a difficult time for their
family they are awaiting word with heavy
hearts Tony yeah I was just thinking
about those grandparents Jonathan's a
troubling story on multiple levels thank
you very much